Think of it like playing darts. The standard height from the floor to the
bullseye is 5 feet 8 inches, and then you have to stand 7 feet 9 and 1 fourth
inches back from the dartboard. Then dartboard makers had to decide how big the
dartboard should be. Bigger targets or even the wall are easier to hit. But
it's also more likely we hit them by chance. Smaller targets are harder to hit,
but when we hit them, we can be more confident we didn't hit them by chance. So
the bulls eye should be big enough that it's possible to hit it, but small
enough so that if we hit it, it's due to skill. There has to be a balance.
These targets on a dart board are analogous to the critical regions, with the
boundary of each region on the dartboard analogous to the different alpha
levels. We can easily get a mean within this area, in the middle of the
distribution, but if a mean lands beyond a z score of 1.64, the probability of
getting this mean is less than 0.05, the alpha level, and it's not likely to
have occurred by chance. It's even more unlikely to occur by chance if the mean
lands beyond z equals 2.32. The probability there is .01, and it's super
unlikely to have occurred by chance. If the mean lands beyond z equals 3.08.
This is like striking the bullseye.